There’s never a good day for a supervillain attack
or a tense feud with your closest sibling, and for
The Mighty Thor, this day was turning out to be
both. As the self-proclaimed strongest Avenger
flung his body across the planet Earth using his
trusty magical hammer, Mjollnir, the Asgardian
steeled himself for yet another confrontation with
his evil half-brother Loki: The God of Mischief.
As per usual, Loki was using terrorizing the
humans of a random city, using his illusions to
manifest imaginary dragons and other ferocious
beasts. And what was also usual is Thor had no
idea what his brother’s motive or endgame was.
All the God of Thunder knew was that this kind
of tricky-dickery would not be stood for.
While these terrible creatures weren’t real,
they were still very frightening to the
earthlings. Civilians were running around in every
direction away from Loki, and this was causing
all kinds of chaos and traffic disturbances.
Regardless of what Loki’s plan was, Thor knew
that his brother had to be stopped before
things escalated further. On Earth, humans
needed to rely on vehicles to get around,
and even the slightest inconvenience in
transportation could lead to disaster.
Thor touched down in the same city square
where Loki was unleashing his horde of
make-believe monsters: landing in
a classically cool superhero way.
“Hello, Brother.” Thor proclaimed. “I don’t
suppose you’ll be stopping this without a fight.”
Loki smiled a mischievous smile and replied.
“Ah, Thor. We meet again. And once again,
you’re wrong! I can stop this any time I want!”
Loki swiftly moved his hands through the air,
casting a new spell to dismiss his diabolical
decoys. The illusions dispersed naturally,
and soon the two brothers were
facing each other one on one.
“See!” Loki chuckled.
Thor was rightly confused by his
brother’s unpredictable actions.
He pointed Mjollnir towards
Loki in an accusatory manner.
“No illusions? No sorcery? What are you
really playing at, Loki?” said Thor.
And then, Loki reached into his robes and
produced an unusual cube-shaped object. As
his good brother was all too aware, this
particular cube was the latest in a long
line of mysterious and powerful cubes that
Loki had used for his various evil plans.
Loki juggled the unknown cube
from one hand to the other,
then waved it in the air in front of
Thor and began to laugh maniacally.
“All I need to do is open
this ancient box of mysteries,
and I’ll become completely unstoppable!”
“Don’t you dare do it, Loki!” Thor shouted. “That
sort of power will be misused in your hands! ”
“That’s precisely the point!”
Loki continued to laugh, and reached for what
appeared to be the lid of the cube. He grabbed the
top of it and made a show of beginning to twist.
This sent Thor’s heroic instincts into high gear,
and he threw Mjollnir at the cube, knocking
it out of Loki’s grasp. As the cube flew
away from the grinning villain, Thor dove to
retrieve it before his brother had the chance.
He soon held the strange item in one hand
while calling Mjollnir back to the other.
As Thor stared at the cube, pondering its purpose,
Loki stretched out his hands in desperation.
“Oh no, not my cube! If you open it
now, my plan is doomed!” Loki pleaded.
Thor responded with a laugh of his own. “Nice
try, brother! But I’m going to open it now!”
And so The God of Thunder did. Thor popped
the cube’s lid and braced himself for whatever
cosmic force was about to be released. But for
some reason, nothing happened. Still curious,
Thor took a cautious look inside. As
it turned out, the only thing within
this apparently nonmagical cube was what
appeared to be a fully-developed photograph.
“What in Odin’s name is this?”
Thor removed the image and held it close to
his face. It appeared to depict an emaciated,
pale humanoid with long, spindly limbs standing
in the corner of a compact room with smooth
metal walls. In all his many years traveling
the nine realms, Thor had never seen anything
like it. Whatever the creature actually
was, it certainly did not look happy.
Of course, what Thor was actually looking at
was a photo taken of SCP-096 inside of its
containment unit at The Foundation. The Shy Guy,
as its nickname suggested, did not like having
its face looked at, even via secondary means
such as video recording or photography. The
anomalous humanoid’s sense of shame about its own
appearance was so great that a mere moment after
Thor fixed his Asgardian eyes upon its visage,
SCP-096 began to stir in its containment unit.
The creature wailed and covered its face with
both of the hands on its long, sinewy arms.
It screamed and carried on for the duration of
two minutes, after which point SCP-096 sprinted
towards the steel walls of its containment
unit and smashed through. Reaching speeds
greater than most motor vehicles, SCP-096
began to zero in on Thor’s location.
As was always the case when
another being saw its face,
The Shy Guy was compelled to utterly annihilate
the offending observer with its bare hands.
Thor himself had no idea that SCP-096 was en
route and continued to squint at the photograph,
perplexed by the mysterious entity depicted
therein. Loki now resumed his mad laughter,
because once more, he had managed
to trick his foolish brother into
falling for one of his ingenious schemes.
“Make sure to get a good look,
brother.” Loki gloated. “Yes,
look at the fell creature that will
bring about your inevitable destruction!”
Thor was annoyed. “If you think that showing
me a gross picture of some lowly wretch
will strike fear into my heart, you’ve truly
forgotten what it means to be an Asgardian!”
“Save your sentiments for the Halls of Valhalla!”
The green-clad evildoer cackled.
“You’ll be there soon enough.”
And with that, Loki used a charm to turn
himself invisible and vanished completely
from Thor’s sight. Thor stomped his foot
on the ground angrily. He wasn’t sure how,
but it seemed as though Loki had
gotten the last laugh once again.
“Loki!” He shouted after his brother.
“Come back here and face me with honor!”
Then the God of Thunder sighed
pensively and thought to himself:
Who am I kidding? He’s never going to change.
Thor looked at his trusty hammer. “Mjollnir,
old friend. It seems we’ve saved the day yet
again. Shall we away back to Avenger’s HQ?”
He then shook Mjollnir up and down
like a puppeteer simulating a nod.
“Splendid idea, Mjollnir. Glad you thought of
it.” Thor chuckled, already in better spirits.
That’s when he began to hear the footsteps
of SCP-096 rapidly approaching him. Thor
turned his head towards the sound and
saw the same disquieting creature from
the photograph that was inside Loki’s cube
zooming headlong towards him with reckless
abandon. The Asgardian blinked. He
almost couldn’t believe his eyes.
Whatever that thing was, it was faster than Thor
could have possibly anticipated. Was it
looking for the photograph? He wondered.
“Hello there!” Thor called
out as SCP-096 continued
to make a beeline at the caped superhero.
The God of Thunder waved the
photograph of SCP-096 in the air.
“Is this your selfie?”
In all likelihood, Loki had been his usual
conniving self and stole that self-portrait
from the miserable creature hoping that it
would mistake Thor for the thief. The God
of Mischief had probably even used a glamour
to disguise himself as Thor when it did the
deed. Thor believed that all he had to do was
clear up this misunderstanding and he and the
strange beast could go their separate ways without
coming to blows. It was a naive, optimistic, and
ultimately incorrect view of the situation, but
at least the hero’s heart was in the right place.
“I don’t need this so…” Thor said,
trying to reason with the creature.
“You can have it back if you like.”
But SCP-096 showed no signs of stopping and was
seemingly enraged even further by Thor flaunting
its decidedly unflattering photograph. The Shy
Guy kicked the ground and shot forward with a
powerful burst of speed. One of its elongated
arms slammed into Thor’s face with enough force
to nearly knock the Asgardian off his feet.
Thor was so surprised that he instinctively
whacked the creature with Mjollnir, sending
SCP-096 careening backwards down the street.
It wasn’t launched more than a dozen feet
before its powerful arms and legs dug into
the pavement and slowed its velocity
to zero. Even though the thing from
the photo had taken a direct hit from
Mjollnir, it barely looked phased on a
physical level. One thing was for sure, The
Shy Guy was still incredibly distraught,
and it was directing all of those negative
emotions towards The God of Thunder.
What was this thing? Thor wondered to himself.
It was fast, strong, and durable to an
unearthly degree. If this thing wanted
to engage in single combat, Thor wouldn’t
back down. He was an Asgardian warrior,
and sometimes that meant facing challenges
head-on no matter how suddenly they arose.
Still, his time with The Avengers had
taught him that having a clear reason
to fight was sometimes even more
important than the fight itself.
“Hey, quick question! What are
you?” He said aloud to the creature.
SCP-096 didn’t answer. Within seconds,
it was on Thor again like a bilgesnipe
on another bilgesnipe. The screaming humanoid
swung wildly, pelting its opponent with blow
after blow. Thor tried once more to
communicate with his unknown enemy.
“I have no quarrel with you, weird one,” Thor
spoke. “So take your noodle arms and begone!”
For all of its relentless ferocity,
the humanoid abomination left countless
openings that a seasoned warrior like
Thor could easily exploit. Of course,
most mortal combatants would be
unable to endure the brunt of
the Shy Guy’s attacks for long enough,
but true to his nature: Thor was a god.
The Avenger struck back with another crushing blow
from Mjollnir, aimed straight for
the creature’s sternum. Once again,
the monster was pushed back for a moment
and then resumed its maddening onslaught.
A blow like that should have at least
busted a rib or two. Were the bones of
this horrible thing made of vibranium or some
other rare metal out of the depths of space?
Thor realized he was now fighting on the
defensive. While he had faced foes in the
past with much greater physical strength than
The Shy Guy - including his superhero colleague
Bruce Banner’s mean, green, everloving alter
ego The Incredible Hulk - the sheer tenacity
of SCP-096 meant that being careless
with his own protection could lead to
Thor taking unnecessary hits that would
eventually wear him down in a prolonged
fight. The wiry humanoid certainly didn’t
show any signs of slowing down or tiring,
even though it had to be expending
a lot of energy to move so quickly.
Between his alternating deflections
and counterblows against the creature,
Thor mulled over his brother’s words from earlier.
Loki was right about one thing. This is a
fell creature if there ever was one. Still,
as long as there is thunder in my blood,
I won’t allow a hairless cur like this
to bring me my own destruction. Think,
Thor. What would Stark do at a time like this?
He says he’s the smart one, after all. Humor him.
With his highly sophisticated tactical acumen that
was similar to Iron Man except for the fact that
was much better and stronger, Thor efficiently
assessed his current situation. While the pale
beast was undoubtedly violent and far mightier
than most terrestrial creatures, its attention and
all the brute strength that came with it had been
fixated solely on Thor since it arrived in the
city. The Asgardian’s best guess as to why was the
photograph that Loki had tricked him into looking
at. Devious trickster that he is, Loki must
have known that this thing would hunt down and
attempt to pulverize the latest being to see its
face. Which now, of course, happened to be Thor.
The revelation of this fact meant
that Thor no longer had to worry
about the fate of civilians if he chose to
relocate to a less populated battlefield,
since the creature was guaranteed to follow him.
Nobody else needed to get hurt. While running
from a fight wasn’t exactly the
God of Thunder’s favorite strategy,
it would massively reduce the chance
of collateral damage. He’d be saving
lives in classic Avengers fashion. Captain
America would be so proud, not that Thor
would have done it any differently even if he
didn't have the star-spangled man’s approval.
SCP-096 leaped in towards Thor to deliver its
next walloping strike, but the Asgardian quickly
grabbed it by the wrist and pulled the furious
creature off of its feet. He lifted it up and
over his head before slamming it down hard into
the pavement. With a bit of space between himself
and his anomalous foe, Thor began to swing
Mjollnir around by its leathery wrist strap.
The Shy Guy desperately scrambled to its
feet to resume the attack, but by that time,
Thor had already thrown himself skyward.
He soared between the buildings using the
force of Mjollnir’s trajectory, making
it his mission to exit the city as soon
as possible. Thor looked down to see that
SCP-096 was following him along the ground,
exactly as he had predicted it would.
While the battle with the beast would
most certainly continue the second he
dropped back to the earth’s surface,
he could rest assured that the place where the
showdown would take place could be chosen by him.
He saw an evergreen forest on
a nearby mountain and decided
that it would do nicely as a place to finish this.
I’m sure no one will mind a few stray bolts
of lightning around here. Thor thought.
The God of Thunder was amused by the prospect of
going all out against this being. Even though it
probably had its reasons for wanting
to destroy the one that saw its face,
Thor was past the point of taking chances
on diplomacy. This distressing creature was,
after all, an adversary that Loki had plotted
to send after him through one means or another,
and because of that, it was likely to have power
and guile to spare. Thor breaking a sweat to
vanquish the thing would be a fitting replacement
for the fight that he would have had with Loki.
Thor’s feet hit the ground on a
stony mountain ledge, and once again,
he struck that iconic superhero landing pose.
Remarkably, the Shy Guy had kept pace with
Thor almost the entire time the Asgardian
had been flying, smashing through every
tree and boulder that stood in its path.
Even so, Thor was more than ready for it.
Storm clouds rumbled overhead. The
sky above the mountain was trembling
as Thor decided that it was time to bring
down the thunder on his unfortunate foe.
Boom! Crack!
The heavens flashed with electrical might as
Thor channeled the energy from several lightning
bolts through mjollnir before unleashing a
consolidated blast of unbridled power onto
SCP-096. The Shy Guy didn’t even attempt
to dodge as Thor’s thundershock treatment
bombarded it with light and heat the likes
of which few mortals could withstand.
Thor released a second blast, then
a third, surrounding SCP-096 with as
much lightning as these earthly skies would
offer him. After keeping at this for a while,
Thor decided to let up momentarily
to check on his foe, only to see
that there were no signs of visible damage on
the creature. It wasn’t even slightly singed.
The God of Thunder could feel his brother
laughing at him from somewhere out of sight
and out of reach. The monstrous humanoid in
the forest below was proving to be far more
than Thor had bargained for, but he was nowhere
near ready to give in and accept defeat. Still,
maybe this wasn’t a fight worth having
on Earth. All Thor’s electrical attacks
were doing was destroying trees, and the
planet was already facing unprecedented
levels of deforestation due to the greed
of human CEOs and shady entrepreneurs.
Thor certainly didn’t want to be part of the
problem, and now that it was occurring to him,
he realized that he should probably try to do
something about that once this situation with
The Shy Guy was resolved. It didn’t matter how
close of a friend Elon Musk was to Tony Stark,
these overreaching humans had to be given
a stern talking to by The God of Thunder:
with or without a hammer in his hand.
Of course, Thor’s environmentalist
concerns had to go on the backburner
for now since SCP-096 was advancing towards
him once again with no hint of slowing down.
Let’s see if you can follow me back to
Asgard, you son of an elf. Thor thought.
He held his hammer aloft and counted on Heimdall
to deploy the bifrost. The rainbow bridge arrived
seconds before SCP-096’s arms would have reached
the Asgardian, and as expected, it instantly
carried Thor into the interdimensional space
between his destinations. Amidst the swirling
sea of multicolored lights, Thor shared a
laugh with nobody but himself and Mjollnir.
“So much for Shy Guy!” said Thor. “Looks like
it’ll have to resolve those body image issues on
its own time. I’ve been through something similar,
so I can relate. Best of luck, pitiful beast!”
But while Thor was congratulating himself for
his strategic retreat, he almost didn’t notice
that his foe hadn’t actually stopped
in its pursuit. As a matter of fact,
SCP-096 was currently inside of the Bifrost and
swiftly gaining on The God of Thunder. The Shy
Guy was truly running in the 90s. Well, 90 miles
per hour or more, but it made the same difference.
The creature grabbed Thor by his ankles and
screeched in mortified rage. Thor punched
SCP-096 in the face, hoping to shake it off
but to no avail. The two opponents spun through
the bifrost locked together in an unbreakable
grapple until they collided with the walls of the
interdimensional space. Thor knew exactly where
this was going, and he wasn’t happy about it.
Like a sheet of ice composed of photons, the outer
limits of the bifrost broke away, sending both
combatants shooting off into the void. Seconds
later, a wormhole spit Thor and SCP-096 out in
a vast junkyard filled with the remains of
countless spaceships and alien lifeforms.
Great. I’m trapped in this garbage world again.
I knew I should have picked somewhere closer.
Thor shook off the nauseating effects
of the failed interdimensional trip,
SCP-096 was already hale and hearty for another
round. Thor grimaced with frustrated anticipation.
“How about a quick five-minute rest?” Thor
implored The Shy Guy. “Gentleman’s truce?”
SCP-096 roared and dashed forth, more
crazed than ever. Thor exhaled in futility.
“I thought not.”
He whipped Mjollnir around and hurled it
straight for SCP-096’s skull. The reliable
uru-steal hammer made contact, knocking the
creature onto its back. At the very least,
Thor could always count on his signature
weapon to help him out. Or could he…?
When the Asgardian tried to call the
hammer back, he was shocked to find
that SCP-096 had somehow grabbed ahold
of its handle. Even more surprisingly,
it now appeared to be wielding the
hammer as easily as Thor could.
Son of a… You’re telling me that thing is worthy?
The Shy Guy, now with Mjollnir in hand, pounced
on Thor, swinging the hammer with no technique
or finesse. It was everything Thor could do to
simply avoid the creature’s range. A blow from
Mjollnir was enough to cause serious injury
to even the most formidable Asgardian warrior.
“Damn you, Mjollnir! We talked about this!”
Thor thundered. “We’re friends, aren’t we?”
But none of his words could get through to the
hammer now that it was in the hand of SCP-096.
In an act of righteous defiance, Thor
called the fury of lightning into his
own body. This strange foe which had come
from Loki’s latest prank was about to find
out what happened when a God of Thunder got
serious. With the speed of a lightning bolt,
Thor flew at SCP-096 and punched it so
hard that its grip loosened on Mjollnir
for all but a second. And that second was
all Thor needed to reclaim his weapon.
His hand clung tightly to Mjollnir’s handle
as he swung the weapon into the Shy Guy’s
body with all his might. The shockwave of
this forceful blow launched piles of debris
high into the air and sent SCP-096 tumbling
across the surface of the planet like a thrown
piece of discarded food at an Asgardian
feast. With another pulse of electricity,
Thor magnetized the portions of the rubble
which contained spaceship parts and used his
manipulation of that same energy to bury the Shy
Guy in the deepest heap of trash he could manage.
And with one last flick of Mjollnir, Thor sent
himself hurtling through the largest wormhole in
the sky above and back into space where it would
be far more difficult for his foe to follow him.
Finally, with some distance,
Thor breathed with relief.
You almost had me that time, Loki. What
an unusual being. Fought like a berserker,
but was somehow also pure of
heart. A kindred spirit to myself,
perhaps? Even so, I truly hope
to never meet that thing again.
Now go check out “SCP-096 VS SCP-343”
and “SCP-049 Cures SCP-096 of the
Pestilence?!” for more battles with
this self-conscious skinny legend!